then we have watchdogs to which looks
fine yeah looks good Lassiter yeah
topical for that final trailer with him
you're cutting between transition stuff
like that it was really cool yeah I'm
great music selection yeah the the music
that game has so far like from what I've
seen it's been great they're like a
really well curated selection of license
tracks and now the world is much
brighter and much more alive and as much
more personality it's just a game that I
actually want to play in the first game
with so like stark and empty it's really
nice to see that it kind of grew a sense
of humor between the first and second
games there's certain moments in there
where it's like feels like pandering to
Millennials a little too hard it was
very forced but if you can kind of
stomach that I think it actually looks
like a very fun game building on what
the first game did well but injecting
welcome new personality also I don't
know why this hacker dude is wearing the
name of his hacking group on his t-shirt
what is this there my cool dead and then
he goes yeah like have stuff
infiltration mission and immediately
like no I don't know one of his senses
by putting blasting music honestly when
you don't do it like what if someone
walks up behind you and start smacks you
in the back of the head you wanna hear
it coming there's absolutely nice yeah
and also the news that watch dogs is
gonna be turned into a movie which job
yeah they were they already said that I
wasn't really good I don't know why we
had a Sony's Jim Ryan come out to talk
about that like because they wanted to
another Jordi on stage that's why I
guess I guess Sony Pictures might be
involved in some capacity then
you